e
are there any apologies for today's
meeting I think we have a full muster
and it's the intent of um our M to join
us but he hasn't yet he
has any Declarations of Council of
conflict of
interest appears to be none any urgent
light
business likewise
none the first uh matter of um substance
on our agenda today is a notice of
motion that's been received from Council
glennis Dixon cenus would you like to
introduce it
please thank you um um your acting
Worship in accordance with Clause 241 of
council standing orders I propose an
amendment to the motion passed at the
council meeting on the 10th of October
2023 relating to the planting of five
crab apple trees in the Main Street
elected members when debating this issue
were unaware of the
$300 daily charge incurred if the trees
were not planted in the already
evacuated
holes this is a significant factor given
the length of time the holes would
remain unplanted in the Retailer's
busiest time of the year while a
community engagement process is
undertaken I believe the cost if known
at the time would potentially change the
way some councilors voted therefore I
move the proposed
motion do I have a second for that
please uh councelor Reed thank
you comment discussion opening it up
thank you councilors councel Paul
mcf uh thank you acting worship um I'd
just like to back that motion um having
talk to a lot of the retailers down the
Main Street and uh about the obviously
the cost is a major factor as well as
most of the people just want the the
trees in finished done and dusted tided
up before Christmas so they can get on
with their business so I it's a good a
good motion so I'm backing that thank
you any further
comments councelor Richard
mcfat yes just re worship um OB
obviously the information before us has
changed and uh yeah I'm probably um like
everyone else sitting at the table here
uh acknowledging the fact that there's a
significant amount of uh money or or
expenditure to continue the way we are
the only question I would ask is
probably through to um if it does go
around the businesses do they remove the
trees um if we go so the trees that are
going in are remaining permanently there
was one of the questions I was asked so
once they're in they're completely done
and it will cease at that point on over
to the CEO thanks
St yes uh through you um acting your
worship um yeah the intent of the of the
motion is that the trees will be planted
on a permanent basis and the holes that
have already been excavated and the
balance of the program will be subject
to the consultation process uh but the
motion recognizes that we've dug the
holes we've got the trees put them in
and then call time on the project at
that point and then seek public input as
to whether the process should be
continued throughout the whole of Main
Street but if there was if the program
wasn't P to be discon was was to be
discontinued we would not be extracting
the trees out of those
holes councilor Reed um thank you acting
M I was just wondering if I could ask um
Mr mcroy please how many trees are
covered by the rest of the plantings
other than the Main
Street yeah um just another five trees
and it's down um this end of the main
street so yeah thank
you any further feedback or
comment councilor
McKenzie uh um just one question do we
already own the steel work etc that goes
on the ground do
we yes we do that's that's all thank
you last opportunity for any comment so
we have a a motion on the table that's
been moved and seconded the effect of
which is to amend the resolution from
our earlier meeting so that the um treat
ready to be planted and the holes that
already existing will continue but that
the council will consult on the um use
of trees and the other
locations is everyone understanding of
that so all those in favor say I I
against
carried the next item on the agenda is
the adoption of the draft annual
report um with memo and other documents
prepared by the general manager of
corporate support well n you I think
this is an appropriate time to give us a
a brief overview and and comment given
the length of the
document uh thank you acting H and
through you um we have got agonizingly
close to adoption today um the audin r
committee heard earlier this afternoon
that the Auditors are only two days away
from having Tiding up their Loose Ends
so um what we'll be proposing is
slightly different when we get to the
end with with the Motions but I thought
it's um worthy to go over um some of the
highlights and some of the challenges
that the council has faced this year and
as you'll see um we've had some great
success with some grants from the
government we've had shovel ready we've
had better off funding and we've got
some good projects uh good assets that
have come come out of it like the
library and Community rooms next door
and Wastewater renewal projects and the
like so there's been some really really
good news stories for the year um I
guess where where we ended up is that we
had always planned to have a deficit
this year so in the annual plan that was
adopted we had planned to have a deficit
of 763,000 and our actual deficit has
proved to be 2.4 million now there are
two really key items that make up this
deficit one is depreciation and the
depreciation was 1.3 million over what
we had budgeted at the time that the
annual plan was adopted the revaluations
for the 2122 year had not been completed
and we could not anticipate the increase
that was amount that amounted out of
that revaluation whilst we had budgeted
22 million increase in our
infrastructural assets we ended up with
a 66 million increase and that was
largely due to inflationary pressures
and the cost of goods now in the
construction Market what the the fla and
effect for that is meant is that we had
under budgeted a depreciation so it's a
non-cash item but is 1.3 million of the
1.6 million variance to what we've got
on the
763k the other main variance is en
roading and it's a $1 million over spent
in the roading maintenance what this
relates to was the Streets Alive project
not the Streets Alive project sorry the
The Bridge Project watching Mario there
um no it's a Bridge Project over there
to take the um take the pipes across
this was budgeted to be a capital
expenditure item and it would have been
capitalized had that project progressed
but unfortunately well not unfortunately
the elected members and may decided made
the decision that they will go under the
river so what we had spent today had
been sitting in work in progress and
with the project not progressing then
needed to be an expense because there's
going to be no asset to capitalize
against we need to point out that of
that
919k that was related to the to the
bridge project that was sitting in work
in progress five $14,000 had been
received from W kah in the previous year
for Revenue so the net effect on the
council over the two years is a
$400,000 um I guess hit for one of a b
word the the other areas that we found
challenging were in Personnel costs now
the government in May this year said
that wage inflation was uh rising at the
same at a higher rate than ordinary
inflation we experienced this as well
and we had a number of positions that
were hard to fill that we had to pay um
Market rates at in some cases 30% above
what we had previously employed our
previous staff at um we had some
unbudgeted um positions come on with the
new Council and the new committee
structure we had a fixed term policy
analy come on that had been unbudgeted
which also adds to the overspend in in
um Personnel costs it was the full year
for the re uh for the introduction of
the new tier 2 management structure and
that that contributed as well but
there's a number of and you'll see in my
mem there's a number of different
positions that helped helped contribute
to
that
um I think that's probably a good
overview of of where we're at I'm happy
to take some questions from elected
members Council the way I want to
proceed on this is that um we'll deal
with questions first on the document um
then there's some um recommendations
that are in the report on page four um
but as as highlighted um by Lae there um
the third one will will need to be
altered and the chief executive can talk
to that um I'd then like to put the
motions have a second or and then have
any debate that may be required so there
are any questions um that flow from the
document
please councilor Reed thank you me um
just a question for a Chief Financial
Officer
please page uh 88 there's a substantial
crease increase in
democracy um could you clarify that for
me where that where those numbers fa
please through you um acting acting
M
um right so what that shows is that an
expenditure for democracy and
administration and the variance is
around $1 million on last year of that
over $500,000 relates to the Democracy
activity and it's for unbudgeted items
so in the past we've never had a budget
budget in democracy for legal expenses
we've never needed it um this year we've
had the year under review we've had
$104,000 worth of um legal expenses in
in that activity there have also been
some facilitated conversations that
elected members have been part of that
were unbudgeted there's um the costs of
additional training for new for new
members there's an increase in travel
expenditure for um I guess an new to go
up and and M and great and and attend a
lot more meetings so compared to our
previous me there is a lot more travel
and accommodation expenditure in there
the other part that makes makes up the
difference sits in both Administration
and in I information technology and
combine that around $500,000 as well now
within that um for administration
there's around $200,000 in 3 worlds
transition costs but that is completely
offset by income on the other side and
the revenue side so that has a nil
impact on our bottom line um as I've
talked there were some unbudgeted
positions with the new committee
structure with a policy analyst having
to be brought on board um there's a tto
management structure and at the time
that the annual plan was set we had not
had all our notification of increases in
for software licenses so a number of
those software licenses were notified
after we had set the annual plan for
2223 and some of those have increased
significantly so these will be reviewed
and addressed as part of a long-term
proc plan process going
forward thank you very much for that any
other
questions Mr Perry then in terms of the
um recommendations that are on page four
of the agenda I know you've given some
thought as St re wording for
that um I have uh M thank you Mr chair
um but I've forgot to bring my computer
and I've emailed actually La the
suggested thank
you so in light of the um audit is
saying they're just not quite ready to
absolutely sign off uh and they they
gave that advice as recently as 2 hours
ago in the audit and risk committee
meeting uh just wanted to
um uh alter the the package of
recommendations so the first one will
remain as is as suggested the second one
is that subject to any technical
adjustments requested by Auditors deit
that the annual report for the year
ending 3 junee 2 2023 be
adopted um because all are just doing is
some checks and balances final checks
and balances and that the interim chief
executive be authorized to make any
technical adjustments sought by Dee
along with typographical and layout
changes deemed necessary for publication
of the
document before I ask for a move are
there any questions that arise from the
way that that's
worded all right and I think we'll deal
with the three of them together so can I
have a mover for those three
recommendations thank you K Sol
Mel and second by councelor Phillips is
there any
discussion there appears to be none I
will put those three motions all those
in favor say
I against carried I also want to add a
further motion and I would like to move
that the Council recognizes and
appreciates the considerable commitment
and professional manner of the Chief
Financial Officer and her team the staff
and deits in completing the complex and
timec consuming task of preparing the
annual report in a timely manner can I
have a second for that motion please
thank you councelor
Mell any discussion that people want to
have on that
motion
councelor
Gardine it's certainly a big Improvement
on last year and um I think we won't
quite make the mark of the end of the
month but we're just a fraction over and
that'll be good good
outcome any other comment
feedback appears to be none so I'll put
that motion all those in favor say
I against carried l thank you for your
efforts item six is the chief Executives
investigation into local Council
meetings and workshops and you will
see sorry chief umus chief husman what
did I say
Chief there was a memo from the chief
executive at my request and and you will
see the memo on pages five and six of of
the agenda um where it's highlighted
that there are some current practices
that we tick the boxes on but there
others are others that that we don't um
so before looking at the recommendations
I just invite um any counselors wanting
to comment um further on the
report uh councelor Reed
thank you Mr chair it's much easier to
say that um it's a very lengthy report
um I don't see anything
that's been wrong with the way we've
held our workshops and briefings but
anyway there's always room for
improvement but I do think that that's
something we should um consider very
carefully how we actually go about what
we decide to do and I noticed in his
report some of the words he's used are
con considering or two you may consider
so I think we need to actually have a
workshop to discuss that and consider
it any other comments councelor
Dixon I would second that that I that I
believe that we do need to consider um
all of this document here that's in
front of us there some very good um
suggestions for
us any other comment
councelor Paul mcf I think you you're
you're no thank you just thank you
acting M acting m d yeah thank you um
actually interesting plain English is
what I was going to say here that right
throughout his his report it talks about
plain English and that's one of the key
things coming on as a new
counselor the gobble yoke and everything
else that we don't understand for a
start and I'm sure as a member of public
coming into this it's pling English is a
key thing I think we need to to work on
for reporting so that's more thank
you any other
comments I've I've taken the opportunity
of having a skim read of the entire
document plus a number of the
attachments that were there and I think
the key message that comes out of it is
that there are Provisions in the act
that allow councils to operate without
the public present and we be need to be
very mindful of the way that we um do
that
um given that uh the need for openness
transparency um and it's something that
a number of councilors around the table
talked about before the the previous
election and I see this as really the
opportunity of putting that into
practice and and working through the
issues as I highlighted there was a
number of issues in the report that we
do take the boxes um but we need to be
more mindful I had about 20 bullet
points of what what I'd consider good
practice um that we need to be looking
at and um while the in the Ombudsman is
is critical of the number of workshops
that Council have and the way that
they're reported to the public and I
think that that is something that we
need to be picking up on more and and
sharing more of what we're doing um but
there are tests and there are times when
we do need to withhold information um
particularly where it comes to financial
matters uh contracts um with our
suppliers
Etc um the appendices there was one from
that dealt with why Meer that that I
thought made particularly good reading
where that Council has a policy that
sets out not only for the benefit of
Staff but also for elected officials and
the public um in terms of uh the way
that the council administers um its
committee meetings its workshops and its
briefings and it differentiates between
the three of them having said that if we
are more open in what we do then I think
that the Press also has an important
role to play if councilors are going to
be openly making suggestions it is
important that they are reported as
ideas that are being
floated rather than a view that has been
put forward that the council should be
doing something and I'm Keen to work
with uh reporters and other media to
actually come up with a a wording that
should be used at the front of all
articles that highlights this is an
ideas meeting it is not decision making
or making
comments we have a recommendation in
front of us that the report be received
and and secondly that we seek specific
changes the length of the reports and
everything that goes with it is far too
complex to come up up with specific
changes that we should follow today um
so I think that rather than the second
recommendation that we've got there um
my thought was that um it is highly
desirable that we have a policy um and
that is direction that I would like to
to head and it was um my intent to
recommend that um we asked the staff to
prepare a policy but having listened to
a couple of counselors I think it's a
case where we have um a workshop to work
through a number of um issues um and um
chief executive would you see that as
the best way of actually providing some
direction to inform a further report and
highlighting a
policy uh thank you uh Mr chairman uh
yes um look if it's to do a proper job
and make sure that it's elected member
driven not staff driven a workshop to
have to to to work out how you will
actually work in workshops is probably a
good idea um and you may want to get off
on the right note by having that in in a
public setting uh because it's only a
process oriented issue um and clearly I
mean one thing I would add is that
there's a lot of intrigue about
workshops but hav been around the traps
a while uh I don't know whether they're
going to be a be seller in terms of if
you were live streaming and and um uh
asking people because by their nature
they are actually exploratory
conversations or working through some
technical matter before you can get to
shape up some options that will
eventually find their way into a report
that will come to a on a public agenda
but I think a workshop is good because
there's quite a lot in that ombudsman's
report and we can systematically go
through it yes develop a policy around
workshops briefings uh what's in what's
out but there may be other things that
other elected members uh can bring to
table and suggest that we can add a bit
more um local Council flavor if you like
to that um particular policy and then we
can come back and put it on a on a
council agenda and have a a formal
policy and that informs the public the
media and everyone else that this is how
we do business in this part of the
world thank you so um it's probably
appropriate since I generated the the
item that um I move that the report be
received and that a workshop be held
with counselors uh to determine the
framework and content of a policy in
relation to um the manner in which
meetings are held can I have a second
for that please Paul mcfa thank you uh
any comment feedback yes councilor
Reed thank you um um good good ideas
here from the chief executive thank you
can I ask that we do it after the into
the new year um we're just bogged down
at the moment and staff is too so I just
don't want to see any more pressure
going on us at the
moment councilor
Fraser um totally agree with councilor
Reed that was going to be part of what I
said but um it's a public open Workshop
should that not be in the recommendation
as
well
it can be I'd be quite comfortable if
you'd like to add that to it so we're
holding a public
Workshop
yes any other feedback
comment councilor McKenzie it's just a
comment something that I picked up on
that report there was three words that
really jumped out at me and that is
secrecy breeds
suspicion and um that it basically
jumped out at me and I know this Council
does everything we can to be in public
but it's just human
nature it's just those three words
really jumped out at me secrecy breath
suspicion whether the secrecy is
necessary or
not can be worked out this just a
comment I wanted to throw in there thank
you anything further from
councilors I'll put the Motions then all
those in favor say
I against
carried which brings us to the end of
the um public portion of the meeting and
one of the um issues raised by the
Ombudsman is the way that we deal with
the Motions to go into committee um so
picking up on the spirit of that um I
will move that the public be excluded
from the following parts of proceed of
this meeting me so that we may deal with
the items listed in the agenda relating
to the confirmation of minutes of a
meeting held on the 24th of October uh
consideration of matters associated with
the Constitution and strategic view
review of waste net and also a contract
issued dealing with reseals and preeing
repairs do I have a second for that
please councelor Dixon all those in
favor say I I against carried I would
just like to have a um 3 to 5 minute
break please